[Music]
let's get the stuff that we have given
the business lot which is just a flat
lunch so I will try to make this fun and
move in and all around so you don't fall
asleep
thanks and to be fine I need to move
that's why they have micro so we are
going to talk about easy access to press
stop and I don't have a clicker so go do
this
these lights are in this link in just in
case you don't want to take photos on
your own and then you can do a snap so
to reduce them there's probably click
this supposed to be open to take a photo
we went few seconds before just going
right is in him that I'm dressed so next
okay so before some contest I'm Albert
yeah I'm Mika he's Albert to the
well-known you see to you boy
nice that was a test actually so I have
been working with data for some years my
sister then gft and then shifted and
Albert has been working also for some
years in drove it and then we our
history came together like three years
ago
when he joined shifted have been there
for four years has been there for three
years and now we are separate in all
paths he is going to a new company
called alpha don't go to alpha go to
shift up way high
just in case what's obvious and I'm
going to shift it but to slightly to
north of the world so that means Norway
where that is cold and no Sun and be
Eddie's tech guru so but it's a nice
place to be
okay so I would like for any talk in any
confidence to really start with start
with this a slight now I'm pushing for
it is like everything I'm telling I will
tell you like that's 100 percent sure
and it works all the time that's a lie
it work
most of the times in our specific case
in your case is different so get the
ideas get the main points but don't copy
paste everything it may not work as that
disclaimer on this okay so the let's
start with where do we come from and
where do why do we need actually to have
presto in place so we if you look at
that engine in historically it has been
some someplace that you ask you need
data in your company and you ask people
what is the data and then you go to one
thing which normally is the data or
house team the VI team analytics team
call it whatever and then you ask them
where is my data or I need this data and
they will tell you this is the data and
now we are moving very fast in this
generation so what we are actually want
to do is play with days with this data
touch this data so we want ownership of
this data and I call this data democracy
so instead of a dictate of this is the
data this is how it looked like to more
like yeah they taste from the people
from the for the people so do whatever I
want and they another way of different
see different way to see it is in the
past we used to have these fish and
chips this is your fish cook in this way
that's what you get there is no options
what we want to do in our companies
teach you how to fish that's more or
less the idea but to teach to fish you
need at data link or a lake or somewhere
to face and in the very beginning of our
data journey data studying shifted it
looked like this you get your data
thermic three two unit Alec and wait for
results wait for some magic to happen
you decide to become true and as Jesse
was saying like more money because I
have big data that hasn't been true and
what happened with our users was
something like this actually they were
looking at the passing where's my money
I found a coin inside I still get some
profit of it but what is it and we
actually have people saying
I am is stupid I don't know how to use
this data so in order to prevent this or
white was this happening is okay you
have build a tiny little egg but you
don't have anything else so you need to
actually build the whole thing from
scratch so you will need to build a camp
or the tooling or the data warehouse you
need to build everything from scratch
that means if you wanted to do anything
with big data you need obviously a
cluster or a big machine you cannot do
it in your laptop if you have petabytes
or terabytes or thousand of billions of
billions of records so what was happen
is like okay so first I need to create a
cluster how do you create a cluster if
you have if you are lucky and you have a
Mac you can use an EMR cluster okay
create an email cluster I have to wait
it I have to do it properly then I need
to connect a spark console connect on
terminal keys okay still not too easy
but I can do it then you have to put
your credentials to access to this
three-day Dalek access key is exactly
okay
copy pasting credentials is not easy and
it's not very safe okay now we have our
conventions I'm doing my queries but it
doesn't run I need more machines I need
to configure this I need to turn up so
it was actually a very complicated setup
and what was happen is you're basically
on a common line doing things so if the
terminal dies and the EMR clusters from
time to time they die you lost all would
you work so not happy setup so the first
thing we did in shifted and that's like
the history line we will get to the tech
part the first thing we did was build
something that we called tableau as a
service we already had the block table
was in place but we joined three
different servers into one and we made
this project look simple and easy for
the people so we have this dream in the
company and speaking with people and it
looked like a utopias very difficult the
moment I join a company I have access to
the relevant data for my work so if I
work in the finance team
access to finance data they want if you
see this left slide the left part of the
slide this is the octa button
Octus a single sign-on that will click
you click there and you go to develop
and they use something you see something
like this a dashboard on your relevant
data
okhta is linked to your active
directories Google Groups whatever so
that you can do something like join this
to the group in Google you join the
company in this group so I do that have
access to that data that's what we built
and it was nice that was awesome you
have access to very aggravated data from
the first day and then you could you
could drag and drop and so on it's still
no democracy at the space but what's
happened when you put your data for the
first time in a visual way do you see
something like this data quality
everything is bad but that's good
because you realize that dude data is
bad and that all these throw des moines
that's all the corny to the coin and
trying to get value is actually
impossible if you don't have good data
you're throwing coins away but you're
not getting value feed because your data
is bad so next thing to explore deeply
how this data was or why it was bad you
need to go in deep in in the data in the
raw data actually and see it on
visualize and manipulated more than a
table in in in table so we did something
that looked quite similar to the washes
platform from from line from yesterday
but we used you buy that and we did you
buy that as a service and we put some
extra goodies in top so we put it will
save your code in github automatically
it will create a branch with you juicer
it will dig your juicer with your octa
user so now in your data tough do you
see yeah to have table and also you bite
up it will link your user with your role
with you access so the data that you
actually have access this is this was
very very handy later on with gdpr for
example because you have active access
only today that is relevant to you and
then you it
runs in a circle a stir so you can you
don't have to start a new class that is
one click away click that's my notebook
I start a couple of minutes run things
and it has of cost cost a money
reduction thing okay if you don't use
the class that they machine it dies and
you are not spending money and you know
you better how many people use Jupiter's
opinion or similar tools here okay so
you know the deal you can do things
laughs ggplot habla funny things I'm
very important very important
collaboration I put it very big if you
said you're not booking github and
digitize public or have enterprises
public for the company you can actually
get this call and say to your colleague
hey this is what I did use it copy paste
the code the fork on the branch whatever
you want use it and you can't really
lace actually the code you can use this
for example to say oh I'm producing this
data this is how you use it these are
full hands-on example of how to use the
data how to get inside from this data
use it so that's something that enables
having this kind of things and another
thing that we did and I forgot to
mention is we don't store the content of
the notebook so the data is not a store
is not in it huh that's also very handy
when GDP our game because we don't have
to delete actually from it half if you
by any chance made a query on this user
ready but then this happens you have the
data that's nice but I want ball one
wrote it know you have raw data that's
nice but I don't want to code so what do
analyse data scientists people in
general lazy people are me want SQL
I'm sorry SQL they want it they asked
for it so you can do something like this
is the data that I want from the table
that they want with the filters that
make sense for me and it's actually what
we are going to provide or what we are
we are providing fine so the the big
picture and I will come over from here
to avert this we need we have
data and we have the users we need to
build something in the middle with SQL
preferably with gdb C to make queries in
the data
so actually that's what it didn't okay
so thank you for presenting all the
journey know who we get to provide
presto as a service no Iker already
explained it
we started with tableau then we go to
Jupiter but at the end it was also some
lack of skills no not everyone knows
Scala not everyone knows spark so we
also provide sequel because everyone was
asking for that so we were from having
like this like a mystery magic no some
query enjoying to the people to start
figuring out okay which parts we need to
provide this service properly to our
users now we have at the middle the
query engine no it's like right now for
us it's presto but it could be Athena it
could be ready for spectrum it will be
whatever - Paulo query what would be
query whatever no but after some
assessment we choose this one and also
there are different know areas that we
have to cover now we have the
authentication authorization I will
explain later also we have the
traceability we need to know what is
happening now in the in the project in
the system we need to know the users we
need to know which data has been
excessive all the resources that has
been used everything we need to know it
also we have more or less the catalog
now the the data which data has been
accessed or with data I can access no so
we started with dr. accession of the
intoxication at the end of indication is
knowing who is accessing the data no we
need to figure out who is this user and
then we need to figure out also the
authorization which data we can allow
this user to access for authentication
ok I'll ask before to continue how many
people here use presto or knows about
presto
okay how many of you have Prescott
production well it's less people so
Bristow
it's a before no it's an open-source
project provided by Facebook and it has
one thing that is plugins now it allows
you to develop some plugins and put it
inside the the query engine now in this
case it allows you to develop plugins to
validate the users not to authenticate
the the most common know that everyone
use at least a Red Sea for Postgres or
everywhere is that you have a user and
you have a password know however we
didn't want no two people to to manage
all the users by yourself now we have
already some solutions in place you have
to Peter with users and different roles
and everything with Amazon but we wanted
to reduce that so we change it a bit
this password applicator that it's
already provided by Bristow to use the
Amazon keys know so as a user when you
are working with a EMR cluster or with
Jupiter you have some Amazon keys with
Amazon account key and the secret key so
you used that once to authenticate
yourself not you send this like the
account key know is the user and the
second key is the password you send it
that to presto and then we have some AM
Authenticator that it validates who are
from who are these keys in this case I
send my kiss and then I receive from
Amazon when I do a call okay Amazon I
have this kiss please tell me who is
this user know who is the one that
belongs this kiss and in that case it
was me no it it returns the Iran it
returns
what was the creation day the password
username well some information know that
if we go them to the presto to the the
UI of Bristol you can see who is
accessing the data now you have a list
of the latest queries and instead of
having the
tamazuki no that is the the user also it
provides the principle principle is like
the user identifier by twisting that
then you can use inside the Presto to do
some stuff that I will show later here
you can see you know that it has my ear
n with the user Albert Franzi know it's
inside also there is one thing that that
we have to use is a cache we are using a
one cache provided already by guava my
guava
it's quite good is the loading cache and
the thing is that pesto is validating
every for every query who is this user
know if you have a user password is well
waiting again and again and again know
for example also a presto it supports
held up no I don't know if you are
familiar with l-dub octa I'll also have
held up directories for managing users
across different directories so for
every query it elevates again so it
lands a request to the system for
validating implementing a cache it
allows us to say ok during I don't know
some time of period it can be 1 hour or
10 minutes or I don't know 24 hours
please don't validate this user again no
we don't want to attack every time the
damage zone no like please validate
validate validate no you avoid that with
using this cache you have here the the
wiki from guava if you want to know more
about the cache that are already
provided by Google Walla so you don't
need to implement yourself sometimes
there are good libraries hotels so use
it instead of coding again everything
from scratch so then I explained it how
we manage with handle dealt implication
but also we need to handle the
authorization now we have the first part
that is the I am Authenticator
but once we know who is the user we have
a role that we attach to them no I don't
know how many people here is familiar
with Amazon everyone or these people
know using a Azura or other Google no we
are quite Marriott with Amazon so we are
given a user we attach him a role I'm
given the role it has some bucket
policies
now as the girl said before we have
Jupiter in place this Jupiter it's
Jupiter user it has their own role so
for us in presto instead of building
again now the system of handling all the
authorization we wanted to reduce things
that we are already building at ships
that know that at the end when you start
building a new product you don't have to
start from scratch for everything you
can try to already reduce good tools
that you are already providing in your
company so with this Yaman role we can
authorize a true size the people to
access this data or this other one now
you are from I don't know you are from
inside steam and you can only access
this data or this data this is already
handled by external tool already
provided that sisters who we avoid that
now in other cases if you want to use
this approach maybe you can have
different s3 buckets and you say ok this
user has access to these buckets and the
user has another axis so it's a way to
handle it instead of coding yourself all
the accessing tool again
so then let's move to traceability I
don't know if a date other guys are here
listening use any data lock a it's a
really good product thank you so in
order in assisted we are using a data
dog also we are using Prometheus I'm not
going to lie but they talk is quite cool
it's quite great tool and as I said
before we wanted to know all the usage
that was being done in presto no we want
to know all the users we want to know
all the query resources everything as
when I said also presto allows to use
plugins
it allows you to put your own plugins
inside the Ben Zion here we have the AM
authentication is the the previous one
that and explain it that every time that
the users try to use the system it
launched that it triggers so you know
which user is trying to authenticate
also you can know well we lock also
which keys are unsuccessful no sometimes
maybe is some user trying to use keys
that are outdated or that is invalid no
so
can identify that you know in our
dashboards our monitoring system inside
dated lock also by default
presto allows to define show plugins
it's Evan listener it allows you to know
when a user is creating a query and when
the query is completed even if it's
there any error and also we have the
system access control that allows you to
put another extra layer to know that to
find if a user can access to this table
if can rename columns if cut create be
use whatever no and I will go in it's
more detail and it's wonders
can you so here I have an example of how
it looks or code in the system access
control in this case I'm showing the
table access control know the the system
access control it has a lot of methods
it has more or less I'm not lying like a
100 different methods to to be right but
if you n having 100 methods in the same
class you are going to have a really
long class so we split it in different
areas that I will show in the next slide
but here we have the different metals
like check Tanqueray table check can
drop table check on a table and in each
one will report a metric to data doc a
this user is trying to create a table
this user is trying to drop a table know
so we act like a man-in-the-middle now
in the investor so we know everything
also if you want to maybe to drop some
features just by default in the last one
we are denying renaming tables so it's
like okay this user is trying to rename
table we are not allowing because we
don't want the tables to be renamed it
but you can we are monitoring all of
that also as I said before next here we
have like a cake pattern now we try to
split in different areas all the methods
that Bristow allows to overwrite so we
have like the user access things the
catalog being the schema
table and the bills now we had that one
beta doc reported inside so we have all
the
metrics done by by by free then I would
like to show the we would like to show
the eventlistener
here as I said before is logging all the
quite is created and all the quiz
completed in this case we have the query
created and we know the user we know the
the source the catalog does is trying to
access the schema the resources now also
in the conductor is complete you know if
there was any error you can know all the
memory that was used all the data was
excessive so you can report all these
things to data doc and then you can have
a great dashboards that shows the usage
it was in the beginning now when we were
developing and trying that and we can
know all the users that we have their
roads that you are happening inside the
queries now if I usually strain to
access to some existing data or maybe it
squaring with some tipos or different
things also we have all the accesses we
have the cluster status we have a
different metrics now so
tracing all the usages it's great when
you are building a new product because
it allows you to know which is the
acceptance know and also where is where
we need to put more resources in
development then I would like to show
the continuous integration continuous
deployment before that I would like to
ask also how many of you know spinnaker
anyone is using a spinnaker well it's
just a few a spinnaker is more or less
like a cloud continuous delivery
platform where you can have your
pipelines to continuous deployment
continuous integration your your
applications or different things you
have there are different services
so in our case we have two repos we have
one with what is called docker presto DB
it contains the presto server there we
have our own patches apply out there
also we have the configuration and when
we merge to master we have a Travis
execution that it builds the docker and
it builds away beyond that it pushed to
artifactory
also the same with the plugins now once
we melt the master we built all together
and then we publish the master
I told twenty factory but then once this
is done a spinnaker can be a can listen
to the Travis execution and once it is
done it can launch pipeline execution
that it will deploy a new cluster for
you with the new changes so it will bake
oh sorry it will bake all the da mice so
it's faster to just launch machines and
then it would create some master and
then some slaves also the good point is
that we define it all the configuration
that instead of having hard code
variables everything is defined by
environment no so you can define using
the same presto package not the presto
server that we are delivering just with
a few configurations from them by domain
we can define if this machine is a
master office or if this machine isn't a
slave also if this machine is from
production or quit from staging or which
data it can access or different things
that was easy
also we develop our own template system
it's just a small Python script if
anyone wants it then they can contact
with us and we will provide it's quite
easy just using Jinja it helps to manage
and avoid having a long script
I just bashes clips that are evil and we
are using a spinnaker so here we are
showing know how it looks spinnaker the
deploy configuration we have right now
we have a production and a staging and
then we have the slave for production
and the slaves for a staging for trying
for development and this configuration
is only the one that we are applying to
the master machine is quite simple it's
quite easier to change and it's quite
easier to maintain now we have the
version that we are using we are right
now in the zero to zero four we are what
is the home we are discovering the host
since this master is localhost is the
same you need to put the DNS and then is
the coordinator because
master and we are assuming a role that
is the the one that is allowing to
access the meta store that I will
explain in the next slide and then we
have for example the authentication type
here is the password but you can change
it to LDAP or another one's provided by
yourself you can define the ones that
you want and the Amazon account where
you are working on this allows us to the
1200 only users that are from your
account know because otherwise you can
have valid keys trying to access your
cluster and if you say okay this key is
valid but it's not from my account
I don't want it so it's what we are
doing here finally know the the the glue
presto more or less it was based on top
of hive or it was like a technique
account hive no Bristow and hive use
meta store the hive meta store is where
all the schemas and tables are define it
no it says where you can access and the
good thing is that Amazon is providing
also a meter store it's called blue no
and a good point about using a remote
meta store without recording to do
anything is that you can reuse it for
your different project on your different
systems you can have one half there one
Bristol you can have one ready to
spectrum you can have whatever you want
that use a metal store and you can
reduce it the same one for everyone you
don't need to have different meter
stores you only maintain one and then
everyone use the same it's quite simple
because you just say you're using a glue
meter store you see the region and this
is one part one put records that we do
to the open source that allows you to
assume a role for your machines so you
know that this machine is only assuming
a role that can access to this Minister
instead of opening to everyone then we
have a synchronizer no the idea is that
when you put data to s3
no you want to access to this data and
we have partitions per day or per hour
and Skype Impala or Bristol you need to
define the partitions manually no you
need today okay now this hour appear it
in s3 please I
to this table so you can wear it so
instead of doing that manually we have
one project that where we define all the
catalogs and all the metal store in a
DynamoDB so we can put everything there
and after every hour or every day we run
it with a cron job
we don't put and then we just execute we
synchronize this meta story - meta store
where we say this is all the new
partitions this is our the new path that
you can read also we have some tables
that is like ok this table will have the
latest 90 days or the latest 7 days of
data no because as you know well s3 is
cheaper no but if you allow some data
analyst or data scientist to access data
they will try to access all the data
that they can know and then the same
piece can come to you and say a this
query is taking either no hours and you
say ok let's see what are you trying to
access and try to access two years of
usual behavior data and say well that's
more than petabytes and you only have
four machines so sometimes you need to
limit this by providing tables that only
have the latest 90 days or the latest 30
days also having the synchronizer allows
us to provide this now we are providing
the latest data available so we avoid
this crazy queries trying to access all
the s3 this also this is how we manage
snow we synchronize now we create the
missing schemas locate the missing
tables we update the existing tables if
there is any table that one column was
renamed it was drop it or something else
oh the type was change it was fix it and
then we just synchronize that the
partitions that we needs to reality this
also it's good point is that what it can
be used as I said no the the meta store
can be used by Athena Bristow hive all
of them together so you just abstract
yourself from the query engine that
you're using
so this all this is very good Albert
this is perfect superfine good
technology continuous integration want
to supplement but what happens when you
do a lot of engineering and you get your
perfect supercar super tool but you
don't have actually feel to run it this
is you have to sell your car to buy
petrol or diesel you have to put you
know shelters not to buy some
electricity that's the new thing so
actually these are very important thing
fundamental so these project works
that's the data so what we may be
building you may think know what you are
building is a Ferrari you're building a
Ferrari it will go superfast it will be
the best car ever I'm thinking that what
we are building actually size quality so
has anyone seen this chapter from ok no
so this is a race an actual race that
they made they put a version in Scala on
a race who wins who do you think that
Ferrari will win race you can't play
safe Ferrari fans
ok who thinks the Skoda will win ok you
need to know your data to know which one
of the doors is faster so all this fancy
benchmark sorry for the windows here so
all these fancy benchmark from my
vendors tall is the best tool ever is
true with their data
just remember the fastest that is true
with their data not with your data so
what we actually have in shifted click
please it's something like this this is
our data tiny extract is not short of it
so you may think open this nice data
structure have some some things but for
example you find things like this one
the object ID top is an integer
tomorrow someone chains is important
string you created to tell your tables
in this column is an number and you get
a string what happens your query doesn't
work do you create it also your column
thinking that it was a string ok then
the number we loss of it but now is some
an object it also breaks or you have
these funny things that you didn't think
about and this is why you need a DBA
with a Novus THC but this is why
Jennifer DBA don't never use the @
symbol because it's not valid for a bro
and don't never just it because what
happens when you write this in a
database he will make a Minos between
two columns if you have got with
databases you know this if you have work
with
Casca maybe not sorry for the CAF coryza
trust the DBAs they know something about
this okay we also have this missing
thing so you may think okay but presto
Athena runs from presto you're basically
copying the login for Athena your copied
things from Athena why I don't use
Athena directly we use also Athena but
it doesn't always work so something like
a schema evolution something that we
jesse was also mentioning you need to do
change your data will change from day to
day if you need to do queries for the
last month of data and it changed every
day you need to scheme evolution so you
can define this with some custom
configuration with presto click please
and this is funny because presto is
case-sensitive so the visa perk is here
and the other ways is lowercase so if
you run the query simply it will say all
you have to ID cons which one is the one
you want to call it this is real life
this happens so you have to explicitly
say now this is the configuration ignore
uppercase or lowercase just use any both
are the same column you have to say this
this is the whole thing on Vesta you can
configure this that is some more but you
can configure this with other tools I
don't know maybe yes maybe no scheme
evolution with Athena no for example and
that was an no on using it although you
can do something else that they will
explain in the next slide and then you
have this s chemical you do have
completely wrong data if not this parity
bits so for example one thing that you
have to do is okay SK my schema or not
how do we do this game how do we define
the schema well this is ongoing
discussion for your whole life
something that you could do something
that you will I added doesn't always
work is have
kind of a contract so you have hard
contracts of contract contract something
some things are hot for example the
event ID - backpacker
spoilers event ID is is very important
you have to be a fight unique identifier
from from the source you need to have a
provider why do you need to have a
provider in a multi-tenant solution
what happens if you store together and
give access to the database of two
different sites to the same guy that's
one half access these four letters is
that were GDP are you cannot store
together this data has to be somehow
separated by logic or by structure or by
technology or by physically or by all of
those so you need to know where they
come from to separate it and don't mess
with this don't do any data leak or or
get cocked in this time stamp always on
the type but the type is recommended if
you don't have the type of your event
it's not so important then you have the
object the object is not always
mandatory but if you if the object is
mandatory then you need an IV this is
kind of something and then you may have
other columns that you send just in case
like the ref person to with underscore
please this is something that you need
to make send it but we need to be able
to ignore it and you need to do it in
the proper way so it doesn't break or
everything else okay so the the thing in
my right right it's the physical layer
is how the event is a store physically
and I think in my left it can be the
physical layer if you choose to but it's
actually the logical layer so if you are
doing edge you will say oh this is AB
you this will be on the table select
these fields from the from the data it's
actually view but something that you can
do if you have this physical from the
logical separate it is you can evolve
this very fast so you can define this
and if tomorrow you need another feel
inside the object because you want
another dimension in your tables or
whatever you can actually do this
without touching the later
you have a scheme evolution as know you
will ignore the old data put nulls there
but it will still work and if you just
want to do some data quality tracking
basic you can do this with the mandatory
fields and ignore the rest and you can
see something like okay how is the
adoption of my tracker evolving in
different versions this is the very
basic thing that we did the cool was the
first thing which when we got access to
the all these data track in the version
evolution and see okay
the data is 90% in this version of the
SDK which was wrong so we need to change
it or we need to do this or we need to
change the code so that's something that
you can do they would part is that to
again physical logical you don't need to
rewrite everything you can evolve the
things in the in the left you can keep
onion fields in the right and there
shouldn't be an impact but you can say
yeah but if I actually have a physical
data set smaller I can I adapt it to my
knees I can change from parquet to JSON
from parquet to CSV conduit to XML don't
do that to oversee maybe so you can
actually change yeah I said you choose
if you have the opportunity to not write
the data if you have some advantage if
you write it you have some others but
think before doing so I will if they
wrap up I can read from here no so just
to wrap up now we have a three points
that we would like to share now after
all this presentation explaining all the
schema hell all the Hwy manage node to
compute presto and how to at the end we
were able to access as three beta now so
the first bubble point it was that
accessing s3 data by using sequel it was
like a bulb you know it was perfect
no people business analysts people
product analysts they were able to
access the rotate and on to start
creating value from from zero not from
the first minute I was that that was
great also all the the configuration and
all the manual thing that we am
doing with priesthood all the
configuration it was quite easy no it
was not difficult at the end you just
there is a good documentation to to read
then it's just putting your hands on
there and then after that is quite well
you ain't having cluster like we was
like a two-month more or less of
development so it was not a really
difficult job to do however you need
people to do it no as we said we are the
beginning we discard attina
no because doesn't handle very well the
scheme evolution but if we don't have
enough people to maintain this up then
maybe you need to go to some server less
option like Tina no because at the end
this the the presto cluster in its
maintenance people behind no that is
when you end collecting data from
different countries from different
companies in the same place you and
having a different form a different type
feels different names also using
reserved characters know like the slash
or semicolons inside the field name so
there is no magic tool to solve that no
it's a challenge but even if you choose
on one on another one you will I'm sure
that you will face the same issue No so
just before ending we would like to
share some links of interest know some
of them are medium articles that both of
us wrote before explaining why we chose
presto and how we developed all the
presto solution and we would like to
recommend to if you like pressed or you
are planning to use it on the future I
recommend you to subscribe to the
starburst data a news later now it's a
one of the companies behind presto quite
active so they share a thing is monthly
news later about what is going on so I
will really recommend to subscribe there
and let's say hi guys thank you
how big is the team that was working on
this and how much time did it take you
to do to make this happen we joined the
two teams two people from two teams and
it was when it was started in March
April so we were four guys in the squad
and we divided we did the benchmark
every one to one and then we did the
setup with micro system kind of
displayed we work on different parts
then it was hype real GDP is coming GDP
is coming how common is to work on this
okay so we are three guys two weeks
later GDP is coming GDP is coming so we
are two guys say yeah maybe baby
so it's not that you need to do a lot of
work you have to do it in the plugins
and in the patches you have to do some
some learning it is not much work I'm
maintaining the cluster actually is just
me somehow but it works fine with the
with the load that we have of users and
having something like spinnaker
continuous integration continuous
deployment actually an alpha L we rustic
loss Warren said in in Amazon actually
helps because if you see a machine down
it recovers if it doesn't recover you
recover it and it's kind of easy to
restart the whole thing it's not this
it's not in the critical path this
service so let's say if something is
broken it will take a couple of these to
to fix it but the actual problem is that
most of the times people say is broken
and we go to and say yo is the data
sorry so that's a deal breaker we are
trying to get into this and also in
parallel we for
many of the datasets you can use also
Athena because I said you can just use
Athena
we cannot forbid people from using
Athena it's in the iron rod you can
actually use it so they can use both and
I need depends if something is is not
working in impressed oh and it's working
in Athena we don't say a stockpot so we
have both but actually with the current
flexibility of the datum for this very
big data you can only do this kind of
things with with best two guys and one
in maintenance right now just follow-up
question how many analysts or how many
users of the platform and how big is the
cluster just the cluster is six matches
is m3x large yeah and three extract six
machines must plus the master or seven
actually because we sometimes we try to
put one more of oneness that is around
six seven and then the the analyst using
it actually right now I think is between
twelve ten daily active users it's not
very intensive thing but we have some
dashboard also which was like a because
of our non-negotiable gdb see it has to
have gdb see we have some dashboards so
there is there is actual use through
dashboards
this is also nice
you